oliver jarvis luca meine damen und
herren ihr habt mir mal wieder auf
instagram videos mit dem hashtag luca
reagiert hochgeladen von daher darf ich
euch herzlich willkommen heißen ja heute
zufolge reagiert auf die
die besten
ja vielleicht ist das nächste video ja
ein bisschen hochwertiger mich komplett
verarscht
es ist mit ihr falsch gelaufen hallo k
ich habe auch meinen ja nicht einmal was
fällt dir einfach ist das nicht auf dem
lugano shop.de es manchmal frage ich
mich echt ob ich in die klapse müsste in
den letzten diät volk wir sind dann
immer so sachen aus den fenstern
geflogen wie beispielsweise sticker oder
mein kissen oder so aber hey jetzt
schmeißen war schon dritten hier aus dem
fenster
[Musik]
liga endlich mal ein vernünftiges video
hier von einer person die wirklich was
kann ich finds megaschön denn leute gut
klavier spielen können oder in dem fall
orgel also ich glaube wir sind auf einem
guten weg und ich bin gespannt auf das
nächste video ja ich frage mich gar
nichts mehr hat es ja leute die immer
nur weißes t-shirt dann hast du nicht
selbst weißes t-shirt an
da fällt mir nichts mehr ein
ich selber das video geht noch ein
bisschen der wert noch irgendwie was uns
mitzuteilen
ihr sollt das video licon ist richtig es
bricht beweglich das herzen jahren den
hund zu sehen aber ich glaube ich weiß
den grund und zwar hat er nichts aus dem
luca - shop.de mich auch nicht wie ein
hund rollt und dann eine ganze
schwerpunkt für meinen job machen
anschließen da damit ein mädel gesehen
die einen sprung gemacht hat ihm das
eigentlich was wäre aus diesem video
gelernt haben ist dass anna im weg steht
[Musik]
ein video wie jemand einen küchen lappen
gegen die wand dort also luca reagiert
ist echt das beste format auf ganz
youtube lokalisten.de auch mega ist dass
du werbung für meinen job hier gemacht
hast und die sachen feier ist das ja
schon ein paar sachen gekauft ich sehe
aber gerade das das video noch ein
bisschen weiter geht ist mit
wie blockiert mehr leute auf instagram
luca ich hab hier
glückwunsch
[Musik]
spätestens jetzt fragt sich glaube ich
ein zuschauer der mich nicht kennt hey
was hatte dieser typ da eigentlich für
fans anscheinend habe ich einst ihren
katzen einfach mal zwischenzeitlich sich
dazu entschließen gingen davon zu laufen
ich hasse euch echt so unnormal lassen
der flughafen zettel geschrieben und
jetzt wahrscheinlich in seine mülltonne
donnern aber bis heute ausnahmsweise
kreativen richtig internet wurden in
toilette gewonnen
super wacher action werdet kreativer
danke für das video ich ruinen apfel bei
ist das super auch dankeschön für deine
einsendung hat mein tag jetzt wirklich
bereich
ich weiß nicht ob du mal unter dich
geschaut hast aber da ist ein ps und
nicht 500 allerdings würde ich sagen
können wir jetzt auch schon zum letzten
video der heutigen episode luca reagiert
ich bin echt gespannt was mich jetzt für
einen geistreichen dieses stück
videomaterial hier erwarten wird
[Musik]